Au fin fond de la jungle de Guyane,
commence l'une des épreuves
les plus dures du stage forêt.
L'opération brancardage.
Là il n'y a pas de magouille.
Reste là.
Attention pour déplacer.
Déplacez.
Attention pour poser.
Posez.
Ou comment évacuer au plus vite
en terrain hostile, un homme blessé.
Pierre et Niko attachent
bien la fausse victime
à un simple tronc d'arbre.
C'est bon les pieds ?
C'est serré.
Les hommes se dépêchent,
le chrono est déjà lancé.
Ils ont moins d'1h30
pour mener à bien leur mission.
Ils commencent par la piste Brancardage.
Ça va les mettre en situation de fatigue.
Ils seront lourdement chargés,
ils ont 400 mètres à réaliser dans
une zone marécageuse et boueuse.
C'est une boue qui crée
un peu l'effet de ventouse
et scotche les jambes au fond.
Ça demande beaucoup
d'effort sur les cuisses.
C'est pour moi la piste
la plus difficile du CEFE.
Le chrono est parti. En avant.
Dans ce groupe,
le caporal Sam a été désigné
pour jouer le faux blessé.
On va le voir,
c'est loin d'être le meilleur rôle.
Attention pour épauler.
Épaulez !
Allez, en avant !
Selva ! Allez !
Top départ. Pour un parcours,
une bonne cohésion est indispensable.
Vas-y, donne.
Épaulez les gars.
C'est trop statique. Ce n'est pas bon !
Chaque obstacle est une souffrance.
Il faut bouger.
La fameuse boue dont parlait
le capitaine Samuel
est bien là
pour compliquer la tâche des militaires.
Descend dans la boue.
- Il passe devant.
Descend dans la boue
et déplacez des branches.
Allez, vas-y.
Allez.
Allez les gars !
On ne traîne pas ici !
Pour être motivé,
les soldats peuvent compter
sur l'instructeur Luis.
12 ans de légion
pour ce Chilien d'origine.
Il est en Guyane depuis six mois.
Ils sont bien aguerris.
Ça pousse bien derrière
et c'est un travail collectif.
Ils ont encore la patate.
Ça pousse, ça s'avance bien.
Pour le moment, on n'est pas mal.
Sans esprit de corps,
la mission est impossible.
Poussez derrière. Allez, poussez !
Aide-moi à monter !
Dans son brancard de fortune,
le caporal Sam
en bave autant que les autres.
Poussez ! Poussez-moi !
Malgré la difficulté,
les hommes parviennent à progresser.
Seul compte l'esprit d'équipe.
Un, deux, trois !
Poussez !
Celui qui ne joue pas collectif
est vite rappelé à l'ordre.
Venez !
Je l'épaule, vous me tirez.
Les équipements sont alourdis par la boue
mais le groupe parvient pour l'instant
à tenir la cadence.
Avancez !
Pour le moment, ils sont bien.
La technique est bonne
pour franchir l'obstacle ?
Oui, ça va.
Ça avance devant, ça pousse derrière.
Plus de niaque et de force
sur les jambes, et ça passe.
On est prêts.
Allez, avancez.
Dans la deuxième partie,
l'épreuve se corse encore.
De plus en plus d'eau.
Le parcours se rétrécit,
rendant les manœuvres
de plus en plus délicates.
Voilà, c'est bon !
L'arrivée semble encore bien loin.
C'est pas mal !
Surtout pour le caporal Sam,
il est sur le point de craquer.
Allez les gars !
Soulevez !
Les gars, je n'arrive plus à respirer !
Bande de bâtards !
Sam est a bout de nerfs.
Encore 20 minutes d'effort
avant de rejoindre le point d'arrivée.
Allez on y va !
Poussez derrière.
Les hommes touchent au but.
Mais le sergent-chef Thomas
n'arrêtera le chronomètre
que lorsque Sam sera hissé à la verticale.
Un, deux, trois !
L'épreuve s'achève.
Le cri de guerre
de la Légion peut retentir.
Allez, Viva Selva trois fois.
Viva Selva ! Selva ! Selva l
Jusqu'au bout,
le sergent-chef Thomas
ne laisse rien passer.
Le cri de ralliement
doit être exécuté à la perfection.
Viva ! Selva !
Le calvaire de Sam prend fin.
Il était visiblement temps pour lui.
Il ne peut en vouloir à ses camarades.
Leur performance est saluée
par le capitaine Samuel.
Ils s'en sont bien sortis.
Ils étaient dans
des conditions difficiles,
avec une marée particulièrement basse.
Ils ont réussi
à rester bien organisés.
Ils ont réussi à vaincre
la difficulté de la boue,
tous les abattis,
en un chrono
plus que respectable.
Au barème ils seraient à 19 sur 20.
Cette épreuve n'est qu'un avant-goût
de ce qui attend les soldats.
Au fil des jours,
les difficultés vont encore augmenter.
Aïe !
Et les blessures se multiplier.
Pierre, la main bandée,
devra aller au bout de ses forces
pour relever les défis
qui l'attendent.
Comme les autres, Niko
le Serbe va s'immerger dans la jungle
et se frotter à la faune locale.
Il faut le tuer
sinon il revient sur son territoire.
Les soldats apprennent à vivre
avec les dangers de la forêt,
avec les dangers du fleuve aussi.
Attention, là-bas !
Ici cailloux !
Ils connaîtront le grand frisson
d'un saut en hélico,
largués à plus de cinq mètres
au-dessus des eaux de l'Approuague.
Enfin, le sergent-chef Thomas
restera jusqu'au bout de l'aventure
fidèle à lui-même, intraitable.
En Guyane, reste encore
deux longues semaines
et autant d'épreuves
qui attendent les 31 rescapés
du stage de la Légion étrangère.
Depuis qu'ils sont arrivés au stage,
l'univers des soldats est cette immensité.
Une jungle à perte de vue.
L'Amazonie que les stagiaires
doivent apprendre à maîtriser.
C'est le but de l'exercice du jour.
Gineste est le responsable.
C'est un ancien soldat.
Il est aujourd'hui
bûcheron professionnel.
Il est coupé trop haut.
Reprend-le. Enlève-le.
C'est toi qui coupe.
Enlève-le.
Après sa longue carrière militaire,
il sait que d'un point de vue stratégique,
savoir se dégager
un espace en pleine forêt
est d'une importance capitale.
Pour une évacuation sanitaire,
il faut couper la forêt.
Pour faire un camp de base,
il faut couper la forêt
pour la sécurité car vous ne pouvez
pas séjourner sous les arbres
avec un risque minimum d'accident.
Il y a beaucoup de chablis.
La cause de mortalité en Guyane,
ce sont les chutes d'arbres, branches.
Il faut connaître cet outil.
C'est un outil primordial
pour dégager les rivières,
par exemple en pirogue.
Les voies sont non navigables,
obstruées de bois.
Il faut faire
des dégagements en rivière,
ce qu'on va faire dans
une application après cette formation.
La tronçonneuse,
c'est l'outil indispensable
à la vie en forêt.
Pour initier les soldats
au maniement de la tronçonneuse,
Gineste est l'homme de la situation.
Il vit en Guyane depuis maintenant 30 ans.
On les forme pour qu'ils se servent
d'une tronçonneuse en sécurité,
qu'ils puissent abattre des bois
sans mettre leur vie en danger
avec ces techniques particulières
que s'ils avaient acquis
l'expérience en métropole,
ce ne sont pas les mêmes
au niveau tropical.
On est obligé de leur faire
une formation spécifique.
Ce sont des ab initio, qui des fois
n'ont n'a jamais vu une tronçonneuse
de leur vie vie au début de semaine.
Le challenge
c'est d'essayer en une semaine
de leur faire comprendre
ce qu'est l'abattage
et qu'ils puissent
le pratiquer en sécurité.
On va aller regarder là-bas
Ça on ne l'abat pas.
Ça c'est fait.
On va faire des coupes au sol.
En Amazonie, les apprentis
bûcherons vont vite le découvrir,
travailler le bois n'est pas sans risque.
On n'est jamais à l'abri
d'une mauvaise rencontre.
C'est le scorpion Titus,
un des plus dangereux en Guyane
selon sa taille
et l'envenimement qu'il vous occasionne.
Potentiellement mortel sur des enfants
ou des personnes en faiblesse.
Très fréquent sur les arbres.
C'est pour ça qu'on ne doit pas
poser les mains sur les arbres sans gants.
Comment on soigne
une envenimation avec ça, les gars ?
Comment on soigne ?
En pleine jungle pour se soigner,
rien ne vaut le système D.
C'est pour la morsure.
Négatif. Ça, c'est bon
pour la désinfection.
Mais le problème,
c'est la toxicité du venin.
L'avantage avec ça,
comme pour une guêpe ou un frelon,
l'injection n'est pas très profonde.
Les fumeurs,
pour une fois ça va servir.
Vous approchez vite une cigarette
à l'endroit de la piqûre.
Le venin est thermolabile
donc la toxine se détruit à la chaleur.
Vous chauffez jusqu'à sentir
une bonne sensation de chaleur
sans vous brûler.
Les effets du venin
vont être très atténués
par la chaleur
à l'endroit de la piqûre.
C'est valable pour scorpion,
scolopendre, guêpe.
Vous vous faites piquer par ça,
un briquet, une source de chaleur.
Vous appliquez pendant un temps,
juste ce qui est supportable.
Vous verrez l'effet d'œdème
et l'effet de douleur
va disparaître par rapport
à si vous ne traitez pas comme ça.
Thermolabile, c'est le terme.
C'est la première fois
que je vois un scorpion en vrai.
J'en vois dans les films.
C'est petit, mais c'est mortel.
Dans une bouteille,
elle ne fait pas peur.
Mais je me vois mal
la tenir sans la bouteille.
Après la forêt,
les militaires vont apprendre
à apprivoiser le fleuve.
Dans l'Amazonie guyanaise,
l'aventure est tout terrain.
Dans quelques minutes,
les soldats vont embarquer en pirogue
pour une destination périlleuse.
Réussiront ils à mettre
en pratique les leçons enseignées
la semaine précédente par Fabrice,
l'instructeur guyanais ?
Le capitaine Samuel les met en garde
pour leur sécurité
et pour le respect du matériel.
Là vous partez au Saut Athanase
à deux heures d'ici en pirogue.
Vous avez déjà cassé au moins
cinq hélices pendant votre formation.
Là-bas vous serez dans les rochers
donc appliquez bien la levée du moteur.
Ne revenez pas
avec quatre moteurs de plus cassés,
vous avez deux moteurs
de secours au cas où.
Le but, ce n'est pas
de récupérer à la fin du stage
nos moteurs en régiment en réparation.
Appliquez-vous
et levez ce moteur
pour éviter
la casse d'hélices supplémentaires.
On se revoit dans deux jours
et les instructeurs me diront
comment ça s'est passé.
Garde à vous !
À disposition de l'instructeur.
Pendant 48h,
ils vont s'enfoncer dans la jungle
en prise avec
la nature hostile et les animaux.
Les soldats sont répartis
en trois groupes.
C'est Fabrice qui va diriger la manœuvre.
Cap sur l'inconnu.
Après une vingtaine
de minutes de navigation,
le fleuve ne ressemble plus du tout
à ce qu'ils ont connu jusqu'alors.
Des rapides, des rochers,
le fleuve se fait menaçant.
Il y a plein de cailloux.
Là-bas !
Même pour les instructeurs expérimentés,
ce passage est très difficile.
Une des pirogues a heurté des rochers.
Il faut s'extraire au plus vite
afin de ne pas endommager les embarcations
déjà éprouvées par les stagiaires
lors de l'instruction.
Remorqué par la pirogue précédente
qui est passée sans encombre,
l'instructeur Luis
se bat quasi seul contre les éléments.
Ici cailloux !
Pousse vers la droite.
Pousse là !
Par là !
Après bien des efforts,
l'obstacle est finalement franchi
sans casse.
Les hommes en sont quittes
pour une bonne frayeur.
L'instructeur Luis peut souffler.
OK, on a passé un bon morceau.
C'était très compliqué,
mais on est arrivé à passer.
Le courant est fort,
il faut savoir prendre le chemin
avec tout ce courant.
Là, on n'avait pas vu
les cailloux qui étaient sous l'eau.
On a calé,
on a été obligé de reculer pour passer.
C'est difficile,
le piroguier est derrière
et moi je suis devant.
Parfois on a du mal
à communiquer et ce n'est pas bon.
C'est un bon commencement.
On continue pour les aventures.
Ce n'est pas encore fini les aventures.
L'aventure, effectivement,
est loin d'être terminée.
Les soldats parviennent à destination.
Ils accostent en pleine jungle.
Malgré ses blessures,
Emilio le légionnaire chilien,
est toujours là à son plus grand plaisir.
Je suis content.
On va attraper les tapirs.
Puis on va manger ensemble.
À partir de là pour Emilio
comme pour le caporal Pierre,
c'est le saut dans l'inconnu.
Sympa. Déjà mouillé.
On verra bien comment ça va se passer.
Une fois l'équipement débarqué,
les militaires vont vivre
en autonomie dans la jungle.
Leur première mission : transformer
une partie de cette forêt dense
en un bivouac impeccable.
Le tout en un temps extrêmement limité.
Allez, on attaque !
Il faut faire un truc propre
sinon aïe, aïe, aïe.
On a une heure trente
pour faire notre bivouac.
Maintenant, on fait
le nettoyage de la zone.
On nettoie les petites branches,
ce qu'on peut déplacer facilement.
C'est surtout la nuit,
pour ne pas s'accrocher
ou tomber avec la fatigue.
Aussi pour voir les animaux qui traînent.
Pour ne pas se blesser, ne pas être mordu
par un scorpion ou un serpent.
Ensuite, on va installer le bivouac
et on verra
ce qu'il nous attend cette nuit.
Les soldats ont retenu
les leçons de Gineste,
l'ancien militaire devenu bûcheron.
Ils savent qu'ils doivent être prudents.
L'endroit est infesté
de dangereuses espèces animales
cachées sous les feuillages.
Mais là, pas de tronçonneuse.
Pour se mettre à l'abri,
ils s'activent
à coups de machette.
C'est l'outil indispensable en forêt
pour aménager les sols,
couper du bois pour le feu,
couper le gibier également.
Tout ce qui est os.
C'est vraiment important.
Honnêtement, je ne saurais pas
comment faire si on n'avait pas ça.
Ça va tomber sur ta tête là.
Attention, les gars !
Les soldats travaillent d'arrache-pied
pour se dégager un espace.
Tu coupes ça.
- Il y a une seule place ici !
Chacun s'organise.
Lorsque le terrain est défriché,
il faut se trouver deux arbres solides
qui soutiendront leur hamac.
Chaque groupe
choisit sa place pour s'installer.
Après on teste notre hamac.
Si je me casse la figure,
c'est que ce n'est pas bon.
Pour tester
on se met dessus avec tout notre poids,
on se balance.
Si ça tient, ça veut dire qu'il est prêt.
En moins d'une heure et demie,
le bivouac prend forme.
Petite alerte dans le camp,
un homme est à terre.
L'effort et la chaleur tropicale
ont eu raison du légionnaire Evgen.
L'Ukrainien est totalement sonné.
L'infirmier du régiment
a été appelé à la rescousse.
Je vois tout noir, à cause
de la fatigue j'ai des vertiges.
C'est à cause de la chaleur.
Je me sens bien là.
C'est pour ça que je t'ai dit
lève-toi doucement.
Si je me lève, ça va recommencer.
Viens on va aller t'asseoir
autre part, pas au milieu.
Aidé par l'infirmier
et un compatriote,
Evgen est conduit à son hamac.
Rien de grave, une demi-heure de repos
et il retrouvera tous ses esprits.
Pendant ce temps-là, Nikolaï et un groupe
de volontaire ont une mission précise.
dégager une portion de forêt
pour la future cuisine de campagne.
Là dans les trous
il rentre dans la foulée.
Il y des fourmis rouges, regarde.
On n'arrive pas à bouger les arbres
parce qu'ils sont trop pourris.
Mais y a plein de trucs de merde dedans.
Des fourmis rouges,
scorpions, des mygales.
C'est dangereux.
À la Légion,
une solution radicale,
mettre le feu
pour se débarrasser des insectes.
Ça, ça s'appelle chercher la merde.
Il ne faut jamais jouer
avec les bestioles.
Elles sont dedans les fourmis rouges.
Il est là le scorpion !
Le légionnaire Nikolaï
a retenu les leçons.
Il commence à savoir reconnaître
les espèces de scorpion.
Celui-là n'est pas trop dangereux.
Ça te paralyse un ou deux jours,
la main ou dans la jambe,
ça dépend.
Parce qu'il a des grandes pinces.
Il utilise ses pinces
pour attraper ses victimes.
Il faut le tuer
sinon il revient sur son territoire.
Désolé, il faut que je te tue.
Moi je n'aime pas ça.
Il faut tuer le scorpion,
sinon quelqu'un va
se faire piquer par un scorpion.
C'est un evasan,
c'est dangereux quand même.
L'evasan, ou l'évacuation sanitaire,
un mot qui fait peur
à tous les militaires en forêt.
Il sonne la fin du stage.
Le caporal Pierre ressent
une douleur insoutenable à la main.
Il a peut-être été piqué
par un insecte venimeux,
mais il n'a rien vu.
Tu me dis si tu sens.
- Aïe !
Là ? Tu sens ?
L'auxiliaire sanitaire
va percer l'abcès avec une aiguille.
Le caporal Pierre
veut continuer coûte que coûte.
Je n'ai jamais vu ce cas.
On ne sait pas si
c'est une piqûre ou un œdème
suite à une piqûre d'insectes
ou d'arbres ou de végétaux.
On ne sait pas ce que c'est.
Il ne veut pas arrêter, le but
pour nous c'est qu'il puisse continuer
dans les meilleures conditions.
Pour Pierre, comme les autres,
l'abandon n'est pas une option.
Rien n'arrête cette force de la nature.
Dès le lendemain, il est opérationnel.
On le retrouve la main bandée
en faisant des pompes sur un seul bras.
71, 72, 73,
Ceci n'est qu'un échauffement
avant une épreuve musclée
supervisée par
le sergent-chef Thomas en personne.
Silence !
Rattrape de la piste Liane.
Au programme, l'exigeante piste Liane.
Incroyable challenge pour Pierre
qui, avec sa main blessée,
s'attaque au parcours.
Tyrolienne simple et double,
ces différents obstacles
sont à effectuer uniquement
avec la force des bras.
S'il ne respecte pas les temps
ou s'il pose pied à terre,
il sera éliminé.
Malgré sa blessure, Pierre s'accroche.
Un moral d'acier qui lui donne des ailes.
Allez, en avant !
Envoie, envoie !
Sans pression ! Ne te repose pas !
Un effort surhumain.
Ne touche pas le sol !
Pierre termine dans les délais.
Exténué, il accomplit
un véritable exploit.
Stagiaire vient de terminer zéro échec,
à vos ordres instructeur !
Une performance qui ne laisse pas
le sergent-chef insensible.
Ça me fait plaisir.
Ça veut dire
que l'instruction a été bien faite.
Dans la troupe, le moral est bon.
L'instructeur est fier
de ses hommes, comme Emilio.
Il ne te reste plus que deux obstacles.
Allez, allez ! Écarte les jambes !
Le Chilien veut réussir coûte
que coûte l'épreuve,
c'est sa deuxième tentative.
La première fois,
il est arrivé hors délai.
À la force des bras,
la deuxième sera la bonne.
Il franchira lui aussi
cette nouvelle étape,
félicité à son tour par le sergent-chef.
Stagiaire 28,
piste Liane terminée,
zéro échec, à vos ordres instructeur !
Félicitations. Tu as largement
amélioré ton chrono.
Fin de la piste Liane.
Les instructeurs font les comptes.
Personne n'a échoué.
31 militaires
sont toujours en course
pour décrocher le précieux brevet.
À l'issue de l'épreuve,
Sam retient surtout
l'exploit de son ami Pierre.
Ça y est.
Les mains moins pire que Pierre,
il a dû avoir vraiment mal.
Quand je vois que moi
avec des petites coupures banales,
ça pique. Alors, lui...
On est toujours là.
Comme on dit, dernière ligne droite.
Elle peut être longue,
faire beaucoup de kilomètres
la dernière ligne droite,
mais ce n'est pas grave.
Au stage forêt,
la nouvelle épreuve se déroule de nuit.
Dans l'obscurité la plus totale,
les soldats vont devoir chasser
pour se nourrir.
Une grande première pour eux.
Où est mon groupe ?
Troisième groupe !
Tu as la lampe la plus forte ?
C'est moi.
OK, toi tu vas rester devant.
On va aller voir
si on trouve des poissons.
Pour les initiés, Fabrice,
l'instructeur guyanais
qui connaît l'Amazonie
comme sa poche.
Sa faune, sa flore et bien sûr
ses dangers quand on tire de nuit.
Messieurs, on regarde bien d'abord.
Pas la peine d'allumer
un stagiaire qui est en kayak.
Là-bas, au bord.
Je crois qu'il y a un truc.
Je crois qu'il y a un pac.
Prépare ton fusé Ab.
Un pac, mammifère très présent ici.
Seul Fabrice, l'expert, l'a vu.
Le légionnaire
a visiblement réagi trop tard.
Tu ne vas pas attendre de voir
une vache pour allumer.
On n'est pas là pour choisir.
On est là pour trouver à manger.
Le prochain truc que tu vois,
même un rat, tu balances un coup de 12.
Quels sont les ingrédients
pour être un bon chasseur ?
Il ne faut pas laisser tomber.
Tout simplement.
Il faut tout le temps
persévérer et ça paye.
Il suffit de chercher, c'est tout.
Ne pas se laisser mourir.
Jusque-là, les apprentis
chasseurs ont un maigre butin.
quelques coquillages
et quelques crevettes.
Pas de quoi se nourrir.
Alors pour ne pas rester bredouille,
Fabrice se lance dans la nuit.
Une demi-heure plus tard, Fabrice
revient et n'a pas les mains vides.
Un caïman, frère.
Un caïman, pour les soldats,
de la viande bientôt au menu.
Il était en train de manger un crapaud.
Le tableau de chasse s'améliore.
Un légionnaire a réussi
à harponner un gros poisson.
Il a dû s'y prendre à plusieurs reprises.
Tu l'as massacré ?
Parce que je l'ai perdu deux fois.
Il y en a encore, je peux y aller ?
Je peux encore en ramener.
Vas-y, tu as dix minutes.
Mettez-le dans la poêle.
Guidés par Fabrice,
les stagiaires ont su tirer profit
de la forêt et de la rivière.
L'Amazonie est riche
pour qui sait l'exploiter.
Forts des conseils de Fabrice,
les apprentis chasseurs
commencent à prendre confiance en eux.
Dans la nuit guyanaise, un légionnaire
a repéré une nouvelle cible.
De nouveau un caïman.
Le soldat a fait mouche.
Une grande première pour lui.
Qu'est-ce que tu viens de faire ?
On a tiré
sur la tête d'un caïman.
C'est ta première fois ?
- Oui !
Il a les yeux qui fument.
Quel sentiment ça te donne de chasser
dans la nuit en Amazonie ?
C'est impressionnant.
C'est vraiment intéressant !
Avec plus ou moins de réussite
et après trois heures de chasse,
chaque groupe rentre
au bivouac avec son butin.
Toute cette viande et ce poisson,
il faut maintenant le préparer.
Là aussi, des règles
bien précises sont à respecter.
Il faut le nettoyer,
lui enlever toutes ses tripes.
Toutes les choses qu'il ne faut pas.
Il faut bien le nettoyer.
Après l'avoir lavé,
on le met sur le feu et c'est tout !
La cuisson va durer
tout le restant de la nuit.
Demain notamment avec ce pac,
les soldats auront
de quoi remplir leur estomac.
C'est bon déjà pour demain
on aura de quoi manger.
Si on pêche demain, on sera pas mal.
Pour changer un peu.
Le lendemain matin, la viande fume encore.
Les militaires
se retrouvent autour du barbecue.
Ils découvrent la cuisine de jungle
et s'en sortent finalement plutôt bien.
Pas besoin d'être cramé comme ça.
On est en forêt, on n'est pas à Paris.
Voilà le résultat.
Après deux semaines de stage
et tant de privations,
la nourriture
se fait soudainement abondante.
Comble du luxe, pour la première fois,
les soldats s'interrogent
sur la façon de gérer les stocks.
À midi on peut manger
toutes nos rations, tout ce qu'on a.
Non, il ne faut pas être bête
on ne sait pas de quoi
demain sera fait.
Il vaut mieux manger ça.
Gardez les rations que vous avez les gars.
On ne sait pas de quoi
est fait aujourd'hui,
ni de quoi est fait demain.
Ce sera le dernier café.
Il faut gérer
la nourriture intelligemment.
Il me reste encore
quatre plats de rations.
On a bien chassé hier mais aujourd'hui
ou demain ce sera peut-être pas pareil.
C'est de la chance,
c'est la chance du débutant.
Un instant tellement rare
que le groupe veut l'immortaliser.
Nickel.
Celui-là est cramé.
À la distribution
de toutes ces bonnes choses à manger,
c'est Pierre qui officie.
Qui veut quoi ?
Caïman ?
Personne d'autre ?
Le gars, réveillez-vous.
On repend à 13h.
Tiens.
Juste ça ?
Ça a un goût incroyable.
On redécouvre la nourriture.
C'est autre chose que les rations.
C'est un rituel aussi de rassemblement.
Comme on peut le voir,
on est tous rassemblés
autour de la nourriture.
On est content d'avoir chassé
et d'avoir eu du gibier.
Tout le monde se rassemble
et on est heureux
de manger autre chose qu'une ration.
Tu veux la tête ?
Quelqu'un veut la tête ?
En dix minutes chrono,
plus rien sur le grill.
Les soldats ont tout englouti.
On est gastronome, on a un peu de pac.
Excellent rongeur.
C'est meilleur que le gibier en France.
Après 48 heures passées en autonomie,
les stagiaires sortent de la jungle
et vont regagner le camp de base.
De retour au centre d'entraînement,
les soldats rassasiés mais épuisés,
vont en terminer
avec la partie instruction.
Leur nouveau défi :
sauter dans la rivière.
C'est l'armée de l'air, basée à Cayenne,
qui va assurer ce que l'on appelle
en langage militaire les drops.
L'appareil, un puma,
est en approche du camp de la Légion.
Mais une fois posée,
la mission se complique.
Pour l'équipage, impossible
d'embarquer comme prévu les soldats.
Le problème, c'est qu'après
tu ne l'entendras plus.
Attends, je vais monter
et faire tourner à la main
Petit problème technique,
a priori de démarreur
sur le moteur gauche.
Comment vous l'avez décelé ?
Au bruit.
On entend le démarreur
qui est un peu grippé.
Vas-y.
Coupe !
Il y a du jeu.
Très vite, l'équipage se fait une raison.
Pas question de prendre le moindre risque.
Il faut attendre une équipe de secours.
On va attendre un deuxième hélicoptère
qui va arriver
avec une équipe de dépannage.
Éventuellement on rentrera
avec cet hélicoptère si c'est possible.
Sinon on dormira ici.
Pas le choix,
l'équipage va devoir patienter.
Finalement, il ne passera pas la nuit ici.
Un deuxième appareil est attendu
dans l'heure qui vient.
Les soldats peuvent
se préparer à embarquer.
Sam prend les choses en main.
Tous derrière et puis voilà !
Arrêtez de polémiquer maintenant !
Militaire de l'armée régulière,
Sam a toujours du mal
à s'adapter aux méthodes de la Légion.
Non pas parce que c'était fait,
c'était dégueulasse.
Ça faisait une colonne de huit,
une colonne de six, une colonne de cinq,
une colonne de sept derrière.
Voilà comment ça faisait.
Là tout le monde, par stick ça part.
C'est carré et en avant.
Le deuxième Puma de
l'armée de l'air arrive comme prévu.
L'épreuve du jour va pouvoir commencer.
À tour de rôle par groupes de six,
les hommes embarquent et
s'apprêtent à être largués en plein vol,
sans parachute.
Dans la carlingue,
pour certains c'est un baptême du feu.
Mais pour beaucoup,
un exercice déjà effectué
au cours de différentes opérations.
L'épreuve est supervisée
par le sergent-chef Thomas.
C'est lui qui donne le feu vert
au saut avec une tape dans le dos
pour chaque stagiaire.
À cinq mètres du fleuve,
les stagiaires lancent d'abord leur sac
avant de se jeter à l'eau.
L'exercice se termine
sans casse, ou presque.
Le drop en hélicoptère, génial !
Suite à ça, j'ai perdu une dent.
Petit souvenir de ce stage CEFE.
Mousqueton attaché à la sangle du Famas,
j'ai sauté dans l'eau et ting !
J'ai senti ma dent flotter dans l'eau.
Je n'ai pas essayé de le rattraper,
ça ne servait à rien.
Cadeau de la forêt.
Sinon, c'était super.
Ça aurait été mieux
que ce soit plus haut.
C'était bas.
Je pense pour tous.
Vous auriez voulu plus haut ?
Ça fait partie des plaisirs,
un drop en hélico.
C'est comme une récompense pour eux ?
On dirait une attraction de Disneyland.
Méritée.
Méritée...
Vous n'êtes pas convaincu.
Dans deux jours,
les 31 soldats toujours en lice
vont être lâchés en pleine nature
pour l'épreuve décisive du stage.
La survie.
Ou comment vivre
en autonomie totale dans la jungle.
À mon commandement, repos.
C'est l'occasion de vérifier
si les soldats maîtrisent
tout ce qu'ils ont appris
depuis le début du stage,
il y a trois semaines.
Le capitaine Samuel met la pression.
Pour le rally individuel,
il y a tout un parcours
avec 11 ateliers au total.
Soit vous avez 15 points,
soit vous avez zéro.
Soit vous savez faire,
soit vous ne savez pas faire.
Tout est chronométré.
Toutes les techniques
que vous allez faire
vous avez un temps imparti.
Quand il s'arrête,
le MF ou l'instructeur contrôle.
Une seule erreur,
un mousqueton qui n'est pas fermé,
un nœud mal fait,
c'est zéro tout de suite.
Allez en avant, sac à dos.
Colonne derrière moi.
C'est décisif pour eux,
ce matin je suis incapable de dire
qui sera breveté à la fin du stage.
C'est ce petit rally individuel
qui va faire la différence.
Il n'y a pas deux poids,
deux mesures.
C'est soit ils maîtrisent
et ils ont la totalité des points.
Soit ils commettent des erreurs
et ils ont directement zéro sur l'épreuve.
J'attends beaucoup de ce rally.
Juste avant l'épreuve, dernière révision
avant le test des nœuds de corde.
Sur la méthode, parmi les stagiaires,
il y a plusieurs écoles.
Et là tu tires. Pareil de l'autre côté.
On a révisé jusqu'à une heure du matin.
Ce qui me fait rire,
c'est que les mecs sont partis se coucher
et maintenant ils se font des nœuds
au cerveau à réapprendre ce matin,
à réviser.
Je ne pense pas
que ce soit le moment pour réviser.
Je reste tranquille.
C'est mieux de rester comme ça,
réfléchir cinq secondes.
OK, c'est bon.
Je fais logique.
Parce que tu vas voir
ils sont tellement stressés,
ils vont faire de la merde.
Moi je m'assois.
Je me repose.
Je me repose !
Un militaire ne dort pas.
Il ne dort jamais.
Il se repose donc nous aussi
comme on est militaire,
on doit se reposer.
Le chapeau si des bestioles
tombent sur la tête.
Position d'attente.
À partir de maintenant,
Pas de questions ? Top !
Toutes les épreuves du rally
vont s'enchaîner à toute vitesse.
OK, c'est bon.
Apprendre à installer des explosifs.
Démonter et remonter
son arme le plus vite possible.
Rien n'échappe
à l'œil expert des instructeurs,
comme sur l'exercice du feu
à maîtriser en toutes circonstances.
Ne jamais se perdre dans la jungle.
Pas toujours évident pour Emilio
qui ne sait plus quel avis suivre.
Avec la pression,
quelques tensions sont inévitables.
Il faut toujours confirmer.
Il faut jamais suivre les autres ?
Oui, tout à fait.
On a commis l'erreur de vous suivre.
J'ai parlé avec lui,
on s'est dit que c'était à gauche.
Avec la fatigue, on se laisse convaincre.
Ce n'est pas un problème,
on a fini par réagir
et c'est bon on est là.
Merci.
On va continuer jusqu'au bout.
En avant !
Toujours en avant
jusqu'à la fin de la journée.
Tous les exercices
sont maintenant terminés.
Personne n'a été éliminé.
À partir de maintenant,
les stagiaires sont censés
être prêts pour la grande aventure.
Le jour J.
Le stage entame sa dernière semaine.
La redoutée épreuve
de survie va bientôt débuter.
Dans l'eau, c'est parti !
Dès le lever du jour,
les choses sérieuses commencent.
Un bain forcé, une mise sous pression
qui annonce la couleur.
Les soldats vont en baver.
Avec l'uniforme trempé,
tout devient beaucoup plus difficile
et c'est bien le but recherché
par les instructeurs.
Vous accrochez sur la sangle !
Pour la première fois
depuis le début du stage,
les soldats ont pour ordre
de laisser tout leur équipement.
Ils n'ont aucune idée du plan à venir.
On n'a pas le temps de faire la fouille,
la marée sera vite fin de marée montante.
Il faut aussi pouvoir
ressortir de la crique.
Là, il faut y aller.
Surtout que là
il faut s'arrêter avec un moniteur.
Ils savent qu'ils vont être
mis en survie très prochainement.
La façon dont ça va être fait,
ils ne s'y attendent pas
Je pense que ça va être
une surprise.
Le but est de les surprendre.
Qu'ils ne soient au courant
et surpris par le procédé
qu'on va appliquer.
Juste l'armement !
Pour l'opération survie à venir,
les militaires n'ont droit
qu'à leur armement.
Leur Famas et une machette.
Commencez à bouger !
Sinon ils ne doivent rien
avoir sur eux, à part un briquet.
Pas question de tricher.
En fin de stage, le sergent-chef Thomas
est toujours aussi vigilant.
Stop ! Hey !
C'est quoi ça ?
C'est quoi ?
C'était des hameçons,
des trappes pour attraper les poissons.
Interdit.
La première phase
ils vont la passer à poil.
Avec un couteau et bite à la main,
comme on dit.
17 dans la Stuttgart,
le reste dans la Turg là-bas.
45 secondes pour embarquer
de l'arrière dans l'avant,
face contre le fond de la pirogue.
Le cul en l'air,
la tête qui touche le fond de la pirogue,
En avant.
45 secondes.
Les soldats n'ont jamais
été soumis à pareille pression.
Et ça ne fait que commencer.
25 secondes !
Ils n'ont pas tenu
les délais pour embarquer.
Ils doivent s'y reprendre
une nouvelle fois.
Pourquoi ils recommencent ?
- Trop lents.
Trop lents.
Répartissez-vous
sur toute la pirogue, serrés
et face contre terre.
45 secondes, top !
Allez, allez !
Cette fois-ci sera la bonne.
Les militaires ont intérêt
d'appliquer les consignes.
Ne commence pas à lever ta tête,
ne bouge pas !
Restez bien collés au sol.
C'est le grand départ vers l'inconnu.
Les pirogues s'enfoncent
dans les profondeurs de l'Amazonie.
Arrivés à destination,
ils découvrent leur nouveau territoire.
Complet !
Vous l'avez compris,
on va attaquer la phase de survie.
vous êtes avec votre Famas,
votre coupe-coupe,
un briquet, ceux qui n'en ont pas
le prendront à leurs camarades.
À partir de demain matin,
vous êtes en individuel.
Ceux qui chopent les fruits,
l'oiseau ou la pêche,
vous n'avez pas les kits pêche
donc vous ne devriez pas manger beaucoup
mais vous choppez quelque chose,
vous êtes libres de partager
ou de faire tout seul votre poisson
sur votre petit feu individuel
et de le manger tout seul.
Ça, vous faites comme vous voulez.
Des questions ?
Allez, s'il n'y a pas de questions,
le stagiaire de jour est
à votre disposition et à demain.
En avant.
Les prochains jours
seront les plus intenses du stage,
les plus éprouvants.
Les épreuves en pleine jungle
vont se succéder
pour finir en apothéose
avec la piste Jaguar.
Un véritable enfer.
Le pire est à venir.